Trust in the trusted computing base is
going to come from a number of things
we expect it to do.
We talked about design principles for
secure systems.
And this system is something
that everything relies on it.
So it better be secure
to the degree possible.
So it should be using some
of those design principles.
So let's go back and review
a number of those design principles
that we talked in general for
secure systems but
we're going to see that they also
apply to the trusted computing base.
One of the design principles
was least privilege.
Any time we are executing, the idea is
to execute with the fewest possible
privileges, and
the idea is that if something was wrong.
So, remember trustworthy means
that a high likelihood that
things go the way you want them to,
but there's no guarantee.
There's no proof, as we said, so
if something were to go wrong of
course we have damage containment and
fewer things will be affected
because what can be affected,
what resources can be abused is based on
what privileges you hold at the time.
So holding as few as you need for
doing what you're doing at the time.
You want to use that principle even when
you design the trusted computing base.
Economy is the other thing.
Economy is, we also said,
keep it simple.
It's really more important
when it comes to trusted code.
You want to keep it simple and as small
as possible the other design principle,
we're going to look at a couple
of these, is open design.
The idea is that trust is not going to
come because somebody tells you take my
word for it.
We're not going to have trust, or
confidence, when security
is by obscurity.
We don't know how something is done, but
we basically have to take
someone's word for it.
That's not a good way to design
a trusted computing system.
You do want to have an open design so
security is because you understand
exactly how that level of security
is being accomplished or achieved.
We definitely want complete mediation,
and that means that every access,
that one of the basic requirements for
a trusted computing base,
that every access is checked,
any attempt to bypass the system,
to go to a resource that needs to be
secured, course is going to prevented.
So we want complete mediation,
if that's not there then of course
you will have no trust in
the trusted computing base.
We also talked about
other design principles.
Fail-safe defaults is the default
that gives you safe behavior,
so when it comes to access control,
the default should be denied.
And finally ease of use or
psychological acceptability.
Basically, we have to make the right
assumption about what users are able to
do and what they're not able to do.
If you make sort of assumptions
about users that are unreasonable.
They're going to avoid security
that gets in their way.
They're going to find ways
to work around it, and
that's going to result in
a lower level of trust.
I decided to sort of revisit
these design principles.
One of the things we're talking about
here is the trusted computing base and
where trust comes from.
Well, if it's designed with
the design principles in mind
the number of those that
we have discussed here.
Of course,
that's a question you're going to ask.
And if somebody answers in
the affirmative saying,
yes, we follow those principles,
that's a good thing